Twitter's new video product that's
really exciting me you know I think
Twitter's a heavy media consumption play
the stuff I'm talking about now is not
even fully out on Twitter but I've seen
it the products incredible first of all
it's a new dimension if it's natively
into phones it's going to pre-roll it
captures your I remember Twitter's got a
little bit of a tension problem as of
this filming where it's a firehose I
think they need to go the route of
Facebook and create a newsfeed and not
show everything to everybody because
that's where they're really getting hurt
because we're all tuning it out the
reason I make video in that noisiness
the videos over-index visually and
they're gonna start auto-playing and
they're native I see good things for the
new product but people need to
understand that and they've got 30
seconds there's some length there so
you've got 6 for vine 15 for Instagram
Twitter's gonna give you 30 it's a
little bit more freedom plus all the
editing in the product I think there's
some upside I think you know I've been
using the new Twitter video product to
reply to people which is given me some
depth and so Twitter's heading in the
right direction
you